So much is left, and I bought it today like a human being should be in a body bag
If this is how much is left
Hello
Today we're gonna talk about the FBI
versus Martin Luther King jr
During the 1960's J Edgar Hoover was the head of the FBI he's an old man
He thought communists are gonna take over America
And I gotta get ready for it meanwhile Maher luther king a non-violent
christian minister gives us the greatest speech of the entire 20th century I
Have a dream that we will live in a fair society
Where you know it doesn't matter. What race you are
You can achieve anything you believe in
Like ten other beautiful things and jagger hoover sees a speech and says I have a dream
This is total communist stuff it all makes so much sense
When you think about it like a crazy person
Jay guru verrat called a press conference and Hoover tells these
Reporters that he's invited who are all women for some reason Martin
Luther King is the most dishonest man in America one of Hoover's underlings is saying
Babe you should be nice and Hoover's like you I'm gonna tell the truth. They meet in j. Edgar Hoover's office
Martin Luther King says hey J Edgar Hoover. I love it everything you've ever done. Maybe we could just be
better teammates
So we can achieve peace throughout America after this first two minutes Jake Hoover decided
Dude, now. It's my turn. It's my turn to say what's on my mind
the FBI does this
The FBI does that the FBI is helping you here the FBI is helping you there Amy just goes on
and on and on and on about how awesome the FBI is and
afterwards when if Martin Luther King's friends calls him and says what was it like meeting with Martin Luther King
I'm sorry. I'm bet that's how drunk I am
Okay, what was it like meeting with J Edgar Hoover and Martin Luther King was like dude?
I'll tell you jr.. He's just not old man who talks too much
he's crazy Jake guru ver was the thing to everything that he said he was like what the
She's talking she might be even though. I just talked with them. Oh man's on now
These boss these these guys
These guys
Try to harass Martin Luther King this FBI agent
William Sullivan his entire job is like mind Effie so he decides like I gotta I gotta
write a letter
Dear Martin Luther King. I'm a black person. Just like you I've got a white guy. I think that you are a bad person
You better kill yourself
See the attachment the
Attachment is a recording of you having sex with lots of people the end I'm black sin
When this mysterious package showed up Martin Luther King's wife Coretta Scott King
Listened to it. It was like a mixtape, but the FBI had specially made
Every sex act every embarrassing thing that Martin Luther King had ever done and Martin Luther King's like
This is crazy
The FBI is trying to destroy my life
They try to give up they try to make him give up his core beliefs
Martin Luther King decides like I'm gonna stick to what I believe I don't care what you guys
Do to me
Martin Luther King continues to fight for what he believes in
Hoover never retired from the FBI he just sort of slowed down I
Think that he was just very upset and anybody who has sex
He thought it was a real bad idea
Didn't like it
I'm gonna die now
Goodbye
I'm handsome last notches. I've ever been in my life